mein thema ist ein ganz einfaches ich
hatte vorhin ja schon gesagt wir müssen
die gesprächskanäle offen halten es ist
zwar verständlich
wenn
menschen jetzt danach fragen wann können
wir denn endlich vladimir putin vor das
den internationalen strafgerichtshof in
den haag
kommen wann sind wir da auf der anlage
an ich will nur darauf hinweisen wenn
wir der meinung sind dass es vielleicht
die aussichten eine gibt oder
thematische verhandlungslösung all die
dann im einzelnen aussehen mag dahin zu
bedenken dann müssen wir eine russischen
führung haben die nicht im gefängnis in
den haag sitzt sondern wie der mann
verhandeln kann ich habe persönlich
erlebt wie kommt es dass sein kann ich
war der deutsche unterhändler als es um
den frieden in austin mitte der
neunziger jahre denken und die
eigentlichen messe täter die eigentlich
die unterschrift unter den vertrag
hätten leisten sollen die bosnischen
serben in durften gar nicht nach usa
reisen dort wo die prinz behandlung
stattfanden weil sie angeklagt waren vor
diesem jugoslawischen
kriegsverbrechertribunal und deswegen
gar nicht erscheinen konnten und der
ganze prozess des friedensvertrags wäre
damals gescheitert wenn nicht der
serbische präsident milosevic
einfach gemacht zu haben für die kosten
mission serbe unterschrieb ich will
damit nur sagen wir brauchen
jedenfalls jetzt und für die
vorhersehbare zeit eine
handlungsfähige russische führung mit
der man verhandeln kann die zeit
diese leute und oben bis runter zum
letzten
britischen soldaten vor das
kriegsverbrechertribunal zu ziehen die
kommt danach ich warne davor jetzt
anfangen zu spinnen wir haben diese
könnt ihn ja jetzt auch gar nicht fangen
wer behindert sein und nach den aktien
lassen sie uns bei dem bleiben was im
augenblick wichtig ist nämlich nach der
beendigung möglichkeiten zu suchen
militärisch hoffentlich dazu beizutragen
dass sie kein nicht untergeht und nach
diplomatischen möglichkeiten zu suchen
wenn gut in seine maximalist ischen
forderungen etwas reduziert könnte es ja
sein dass es zumindest zu einem
waffenstillstand und darf dazu brauchen
wir einen handlungsfähigen
russischen präsidenten dazu brauchen wir
einen handlungsfähigen russischen
verteidigungsminister die zeit für die
kriegsverbrechen regionale die kommt
wenn sie kommt danach
charlotte diplomatie ist natürlich immer
der schönste weg verstehst dann auch die
heiße wut von menschen seit er sogar ja
ein us amerikaner gefordert man sollte
punkten killen verstehens verstehst du
diese wut von menschen auch mit dem
kriegs tribunal wasserrechte
angesprochen hat ja ich kann das schon
verstehen aber wir wissen alle aus dem
mini mini vergleichbaren kreis dass man
eigentlich besser und weiter kommt wenn
man vernünftig sprechen kann als wenn
man da aufeinander los geht
das ist natürlich superschön die these
also die idee klingt wirklich toll im
moment sehe ich jetzt nicht so wirklich
die bereitschaft seitens putins sich
normal zu unterhalten sich vernünftig zu
unterhalten eine lösung zu finden ich
finde er arbeitet im moment nicht
wirklich lösungsorientiert für die welt
und deshalb finde ich das ein bisschen
schwierig es ist ein schöner gedanke im
spiel es ist toll und ich hoffe dass
dieses spiel aufgeht das wäre natürlich
für alle das alles beste aller beste was
passieren könnte
aber im moment muss ich leider sagen
sehe ich da einfach nicht viel hoffnung
also ich glaube auch nicht ehrlich sagt
dass putin angst vor dem westen hat ich
habe glaube auch nicht dass er angst vor
der nato hat oder für die sanktionen im
moment bin ich glaube der hat angst im
endeffekt vor demokratie das ist das was
eben nicht schlafen lassen und ich
glaube auch nicht dass er irgendwie
verrückt ist oder sonst irgendwas
sondern dass er ein ganz kalt macht
stratege ist und ich finde den gedanken
ist mal ins
privatleben zu holen eigentlich reizvoll
wir stellen uns mal vor wir haben
nachbarn zwei kleine reihenhäuser und
der sagt ich will dein haus
und ich mache jetzt so das leben zur
hölle ich komme erst in den garten dann
schließlich die spielsachen deiner
kinder zusammen dann schwierig da eine
wand voll ich will dein haus dann musste
bevor du ins gespräch gehst der du
überlegen was du anbietet solltest du
anbieten du kriegst zwei quadratmeter in
meinem garten mein haus kannst du haben
das macht ja kein mensch also das
bedeutet aber was macht man damit zum
nachbarn in der zivilen welt bleibt
einem als letztes noch wegzuziehen und
aufzugeben das ist jetzt sozusagen
völkerrechtlich und als staat deutlich
schwieriger aber das beispiel zeigt
womit wir es zu tun haben und ich glaube
auch am verhandlungstisch damit mischung
aus meinung interessieren
am verhandlungstisch wird putin dann
auch nicht sagen ich will gar nicht dein
haus sondern nur den vorgarten sondern
da wird sagen ich will das haus weil mir
das zu steht früher im grundbuch von 420
vor 500 jahren steht drin war ich mal
der eigentümer und ich will es jetzt
haben du hast das zwar gekauft und schön
gemacht aber ich möchte jetzt und ich
hole mir das jetzt und übrigens deine
autoreifen habe ich auch schon
zerstochen und gucke mir deine wünsche
und schreibe an und deine kinder trauten
sich nicht mehr ins haus vom schulweg
und er ist da ein terrorist am nach am
terrorist am gartenzaun wie geht man mit
dem diplomatisch um mir fallen da nur
sehr martialische sachen ein die werden
dann aber hochgerechnet jetzt auf die
weltlage die die sich keiner wünscht
er ist ja es ist ja es ist natürlich so
diplomatie ohne militärisches backup
wird sehr schnell zum
nutzlosen gerät und jetzt ist er wieder
im zentrum das geschäftsleben ist es
eine wichtige erkenntnis
in der diplomatie dass wir das wir
kommt durch militärische stärke finden
müssen müssen mit dem diplomatischen
angebot was heißt das jetzt konkret in
der in der aktuellen lage in der ukraine
solange die russische führung der
meinung ist dass sie diesen krieg
gewinnen kann ohne dass sie denn die
unterstützung der mehrheit der
bevölkerung verliert
da wird die verhandlungsbereitschaft
putins und seiner leute nicht groß sein
in dem augenblick in dem sich zweifel
einstellen ob die innenpolitische front
hält und ob die militärische sieges
erwartungen tatsächlich aufrecht halten
werden kann in dem augenblick wird die
verhandlungsbereitschaft steigen ich
wage keine prognose fast einigen tagen
wochen passieren aber wir haben eine
chance dass es zu gesprächen komme und
das ist mir wichtig ich will nicht dass
die untergraben wird und es stört wird
ja ich möchte auch nicht dass wir der
russischen regierung den vorwand eben
die im westen die wollen ja gar nicht in
frieden in der ukraine sowie wollen
regime change in moskau und deswegen
lieber russen müsst ihr euch alle um
mich zu sammeln weil das ja einen
angriff auf unser heiliges vater wäre
das ist zum beispiel schlechte wäre
schlechte diplomatie diplomatie ist
nicht verbal zu eskalieren sondern
besonnen zu reagieren die ich bewundere
in diesem zusammenhang jetzt in dieser
lage anders als in den letzten jahren
die art und weise wie die amerikanische
regierung sichtbar hält sie hat nicht
verbal eskaliert sie hat auch nicht
nuklear eskaliert auf die nuklear
androhung der der russischen seite das
fand ich jetzt ausnahmsweise mal aus
washington kommen sehr lobenswert paar
kannst du kurz noch reagieren damit sich
schon weiter zum thema von frau würde
falsche leute würde bei sonst kommt es
heute nicht mehr dran ganz ganz schnell
weil wenn wir schon so eine erfahrene
und großartigen experten wie wolfgang
ischinger haben möchte ich doch eine
frage auch von von von hier loswerden
und zwar sind wir jetzt gerade die
nachrichten dass polen bereit ist
kampfjets hier in die an die ukraine zu
geben das lief gerade als breaking news
ich glaube im gegenzug werden diese
alten sowjetischen kampfjets
ausgetauscht dann durch amerikanische
aber das bedeutete am ende polen
schickten kampfjets in die ukraine jetzt
hat wladimir putin angekündigt dass
diejenigen die die ukraine mit soetwas
ausstatten am ende auch als kriegspartei
gelten können rechnen sie damit dass das
die mir putin in einer weiteren weise
sozusagen aggressiv stimmen wir dass man
erste frage und die zweite ist was
bedeutet wenn sie sagen dass wladimir
putin
glauben sie dass er ernsthaft verstehen
würde wenn er zu hause die kontrolle
verliert weil er ja so einem engen
zirkel ist von beratern keiner kommen
wir an ihnen dran also wer so schrieben
dann überhaupt erzählen das ist
innenpolitisch schwierig wird für den
hersteller ich muss leider eine ganz
kurze antwort ihrerseits ganz gut er ist
gut so
anfragen auf dem grund von paul
ronzheimer ganz kurze antwort putin hat
es doch in der hand den sieg zu erklären
er hat doch die öffentliche meinung
gesagt
er kann doch sagen wir haben das ziel
erreicht die werden das ziel der nato
mitgliedschaft nicht weiterverfolgen
flugplans condor lienz gehören dauerhaft
uns und die uhr eine verzichtet
militärisch gegen die krämpfe zu gehen
große sieg russland hat gewonnen kann er
jeden tag erklärt ich das ist das ist ja
der hat eher taktischen vorteil der nahe
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
ein solcher punkt kommt wo er aus
unserer sicht ein nicht sieg erklärt
aber ein einigt sich der in russland als
sieg des präsidenten
interpretiert werden würde das wäre eine
bittere situation ich hoffe dass sie so
nicht andere